TODAY.
THANK YOU.
UPDATES.
>> Gillian: NEW DATA SHOWS
RESTAURANTS IN DEEP BLUE CITIES
ARE STRUGGLING TO BOUNCE BACK
FROM THE PANDEMIC WHILE A LOT
OF RESTAURANTS IN RED CITIES
ARE THRIVING.
GREG IRVIN IS THE OWNER OF WILD
GREG'S SALOON WITH LOCATIONS IN
MINNESOTA, TEXAS AND FLORIDA.
GREG, YOU REALLY SAY THAT THE
STATE OF PLAY IN THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY IS FEAST OR FAMILY AND
COMES DOWN TO LOCATION,
LOCATION.
TELL ME ABOUT YOUR SPOTS.
>> WELL, IT IS ALL ABOUT
LOCATION RIGHT NOW.
FLORIDA NEVER REALLY CLOSED.
IT IS OFF THE CHARTS BOOMING
RIGHT NOW.
TEXAS IS DOING WELL BUT
MINNEAPOLIS AND FROM WHAT I
HEAR THE OTHER DEMOCRAT CITIES
ARE NOT DOING WELL.
WE ARE CERTAINLY SEEING THAT IN
MINNEAPOLIS RIGHT NOW.
>> Gillian: YOU'VE TOLD US THE
PLACES WHERE THE COVID MANDATES
AND LOCKDOWNS WERE THE HARSHEST
ARE WHERE RESTAURANTS ARE NOW
HURTING THE MOST.
THE DATA BEARS YOU OUT.
LOOK AT THIS.
THESE ARE THE LOCATIONS, THE
CITIES WHERE THE INDUSTRY IS
HURTING THE MOST.
MINNEAPOLIS, SAN FRANCISCO, YOU
GOT THE PERCENTAGES THERE.
PORTLAND, SEATTLE, PHILLY, NEW
YORK, ST. LOUIS, WASHINGTON,
D.C., BALTIMORE AND CHICAGO.
THIS MIRRORS WHAT YOU JUST TOLD
US.
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
YOU WENT THROUGH 15 MONTHS OF
LOCKDOWNS AND MANDATES.
ONE DAY WE WERE LOCKED DOWN.
THE NEXT DAY MASKS WERE
REQUIRED.
THE NEXT DAY VACCINES WERE
AT THE END OF THE DAY PEOPLE
FOUND IT EASIER THE STAY HOME.
A LOT OF THEM UNFORTUNATELY
STILL ARE STAYING HOME IN THE
DEMOCRAT CITIES LIKE
MINNEAPOLIS.
SO IT IS REALLY UNFORTUNATE AND
CERTAINLY THERE IS A BACK DROP
OF THE CRIME.
PEOPLE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
CRIME AND THIS SORT TO GO
DOWNTOWN MINNEAPOLIS RIGHT NOW.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE EITHER
STAYING IN THE SUBURBS OR JUST
STAYING HOME UNFORTUNATELY AND
WE DON'T SEE THAT IN AUSTIN,
TEXAS OR FLORIDA.
PEOPLE IN THE RED STATES ARE
GOING OUT AND HAVING FUN AND
SPENDING MONEY.
>> Gillian: HERE ARE THE CITIES
BOOMING RIGHT NOW.
LOOK AT THIS.
LAS VEGAS IS TOPPING THE LIST
UP 35.7%.
FORT LAUDERDALE, MIAMI, AUSTIN,
NAPLES, TAMPA, SAN ANTONIO,
SCOTTSDALE, PHOENIX.
WHAT IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOING TO TRY TO
HELP RESTAURANTS?
ARE THEY DOING ANYTHING TO HELP
THE CITIES THAT HAVEN'T CAUGHT
UP YET?
>> NO, NOTHING AT ALL.
EVERYBODY IS PRETTY MUCH ON
THEIR OWN RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE BIDEN-INFLATION THAT'S
THROUGH THE ROOF.
OUR COSTS CONTINUE TO GO UP AND
WE'RE HAVING TROUBLE GETTING
PEOPLE TO COME OUT TO START
WITH.
IT CERTAINLY AFFECTS US BEING
ABLE TO RAISE OUR PRICES TO
COVER THOSE COSTS IN CITIES
LIKE MINNEAPOLIS.
SO THE BARS AND RESTAURANTS
RIGHT NOW ARE ON THEIR OWN AND
THAT'S WHY YOU TAKE A WALK
THROUGH MINNEAPOLIS, YOU SEE A
LOT OF PLACES THAT ARE CLOSED.
I DON'T SEE THAT CHANGING ANY
TIME SOON.
WE'RE HOPING THE ELECTIONS THIS
FALL HELP.
AND THAT'S PROBABLY OUR BEST
SHOT.
>> Gillian: THERE WAS A $27
BILLION RESTAURANT
REVITALIZATION FUND BUT AFTER
EFFECTS LOOK AT THAT SHOWED
THAT MOST OF THE MONEY THERE,
ABOUT 78%, ENDED UP GOING TO
BIG CHAINS, BIG NAMES THAT
ALREADY HAD A LOT OF FINANCIAL
SECURITY LEAVING THE
SMALL-OWNED BUSINESSES TO
CRUMBLE.
GREG, WE WISH YOU THE BEST WITH
ALL OF YOUR LOCATIONS.
WE HAVE TO LEAVE IT